aber erst mal mache ich jetzt mein
aufreger und sprechen über eine andere
junge damen und die heißt emilia fester
sie ist bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen
und hat auf instagram bürger eingeladen
jetzt werden sie denken das ist doch
nett was soll daran schlimm sein
eigentlich ist es auch eine wirklich
schöne idee wenn frau fester nicht
bürger aus grenzen würde sie schreibt
auf instagram ihr habt vielleicht schon
in meinem posting gesehen von gestern
ich würde euch gerne mit zu einer
berlinfahrt nehmen wenn ihr eine junge
frau oder inter trans nicht binäre
person aus hamburg seit lade ich euch
herzlich ein hier sieht man es
eingeblendet alle jungen find hast die
nicht in hamburg wohnen können auch
kommen müssten aber reisen und sich der
gruppe anschließen falls sie jetzt nicht
wissen was hinter bedeutet dass es kein
problem ich muss es auch google winter
sind frauen sowie intern nicht binäre
und trans personen sowie menschen die
sich ohne geschlechtsidentität erleben
man stelle sich jetzt einmal vor ein
mann ein bundestagsabgeordneter würde zu
einer reise nur für männer und alte
frauen ausrufen also ehrlich gesagt das
wäre zu recht ein riesen desaster und
ich finde ausgrenzung sollte keine
einbahnstraße sein was fällt frau fester
eigentlich ein nur menschen einzuladen
die keine männer und keine älteren
frauen sind die viren wärs dir auch ein
gefallen das zu tun du bist ja auch eine
junge frau findest du auch männer sollte
man nicht einladen wie herr schäfer zu
der reise also ich kann dir sagen ich
muss darüber eigentlich nur schmunzeln
weil wir reden über gender pay gap über
über gleichberechtigung und handeln dann
eigentlich genau im gegenteil genau so
wie bei den ganzen female am powerman
events wo männer ganz klar ausgegrenzt
werden das ist totaler schwachsinn aus
meiner sicht deswegen kann ich das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen ich bin
ja mal gespannt wie die abstimmt wenn
nicht darum gehen die frauen- haut- und
die diskriminierungs beauftragten zu
wählen müsste sie ja eigentlich dagegen
entscheiden da kann man schon mal jetzt
sehr gespannt sagt würden finden sie
denn sonst so frau fest als wenn sie das
so lese reise die wird ja dann auch vom
steuerzahler gezahlt also es wird ja
eingeladen es wird auch darüber gebucht
das macht frau fest da jetzt nicht
privat sie werden auf jeden fall raus
kann ich ihnen
sondern bestimmt auch auf
datensicherheit sind jeder sexuelle
identität
einrichtungen der 60 dann hätten sie
vielleicht die chance also ich weiß
zumblick von ihr die auszüge dich auf
you tube gesehen habe jede
bundestagsrede muss ich sagen also das
ist eines hohen hauses nicht würde diese
art von inter infantilisierung die sie
inszeniert wenn ich das einmal sagen
darf die bernina ich schätze dich sehe
das was mich wundert ehrlich gesagt dass
du dich wunders denn wir haben es ja bei
den grünen eigentlich mit einer partei
zu tun die permanent ausgrenzt eine
partei die eigentlich dadurch dass sie
wie eine monstranz vor sich her trägt
führt das gute zu kämpfen immer die
ausgrenzt beispielsweise die zu viel
fleisch essen oder die zu viel rauch und
die zu schnell auto fahren es ja wie vor
die auch fliegen und wenn wir uns
überlegen während die partei und die
fraktion die ich aber es war 2 18 21 19
im bundestag am meisten geflogen ist
dann waren das pro kopf die abgeordneten
der grünen ausgerechnet der grünen von
daher für das toll das thema hassen hab
mich wundert dass das du dich wurden das
war das eigentlich ganz normal die
grünen grenzen gerne aus
ich sehe das etwas lockerer nicht weil
diese muss sondern weil ich mein gott
thema feste ist glaube ich ist die
jüngste abgeordnete im deutschen
bundestag
23 jahre als ich schon seit langem
politisch aktiv kommt aus einer
künstlerfamilie sagt ihre eltern haben
sie politisiert oder ist er politisiert
worden im haushalt und reitet natürlich
was nimmt man das so locker sagen kann
auf diesem ticket ist wahrscheinlich
auch ihre überzeugung der frau der
frauenpolitik und der jugend
entsprechend und immer mehr junge
politiker die gerade in den bundestag
kommen wer frauen schlägt ist nicht
leisten sich noch ältere frauen auch
nicht also nur junge frauen möchte ja an
ihrer in ihrer in ihrer post sie in
ihrem in ihrem umkreis in ihrem umfeld
und es gibt in amerika sein wirkliches
vorbild denkt auch für sie
heißt sie herr alexander otte scott es
die ist die ist natürlich so ein vorbild
für viele kämpferische frauen gerade von
der linken und ich denke mal dass sie
sich das auch zum vorbild nimmt hier so
zu agieren also neben ihrer überzeugung
über besetzt sie da eine politische
lücke um sich zu profilieren und
hat die aufmerksamkeit die sie hier
wünscht ja grundsätzlich finde ich das
ja gut junge frauen zu stärken und ich
glaube das ist auch super wichtig aber
warum nicht auch junge männer warum
müssen die denn ausgeschlossen werden
das verstehe ich nicht warum müssen die
eigentlich jung und alt geben also ich
glaube das ist ja glaube ich der punkt
wahrscheinlich wollten sie das gar nicht
so sagen aber am ende soll doch jeder
die möglichkeit haben mit fand ich finde
ist auch in ordnung wenn man sagt ich
gehe auf reisen und suche mir die person
aus als freiheitsliebender mensch würde
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein zu
sagen ich nehme nur ich gehe auf reise
und nur diese runde mit und niemand
anderem dann ist das doch in ordnung
aber sie machte fährmann gewahrt
gleichzeitig auch im bundestag auftritt
und für oder gegen diskriminierung das
große wort führt und das harte schwert
dann in der tat ist es ein bisschen also
ich muß schon mal auf die würde des
hohen hauses zurückkommen und das passt
einfach nicht dazu das essen auftreten
was sie bei einer kindergarten
erzieherinnen oder das ist ja auftreten
dass sie bei einer lehrerin oder gar
einer schule darin was sie nicht werden
könnte mit diesem hintergrund an diesem
alter überhaupt nicht akzeptieren würden
ja ich erwarte mir egal in welcher
fraktion dass volksvertreter innen
sehen ich hab schon gelernt sie können
hier ganz auf die bisher gehörte ganz
gut da komme ich gerne sehr locker auf
rollen kommen wir einmal zudem sehr
spannenden gedanken von miranda der
gesagt hat dass sie jetzt auch politisch
ein ticket besetzt was die
aufmerksamkeit beschert am anfang muss
man ja auch auffallen und mit der
politik dann später karriere machen
finden sie denn nicht dass es dort mit
ticket gibt veranda angesprochen hat was
fragt heißt der jetzt gerade vielleicht
gut besetzt also
ich glaube es gibt so viele
möglichkeiten mit verlaub das wird mich
etwas ganz anderes er wird dann lass mir
ist jetzt mit verlaub es gibt so viele
möglichkeiten in deutschland im
vorpolitischen raum mit den politischen
raum aktiv zu werden da muss es nicht
gleich an der spitze ein mdb mandat
seien ja dann sollten sie sich was weiß
ich wo sie bestimmte reinpassen würde in
der böll stiftung engagieren oder in der
antonio amodeo oder amadeu antonio
stiftung engagiert oder bei den jungen
grünen engagieren also da bin ich fast
für was mir ja auch bei kanzler haben
und bei qualität haben da bin ich fast
nicht unbedingt für ein mindestalter von
40 aber vielleicht wenigstens stück
reifen daher bei den jungen grünen warum
heißt es nicht grünen bei den jungen
grünen phase ja tatsächlich auch und
lange zeit und hat also ihre politischen
foundation ihre niere ihre basis gelegt
und ist dann durch ein mann als mentee
tatsächlich auch dann weiter gekommen
ich finde aber diese gesamt sind ganze
debatte die wir auch für ihn auch ein
bisschen verrückt weil man merkt dass ja
wie unsicher viele menschen sind schon
wenn sie dieses thema besetze den
verletzten bei seinen veranstaltungen da
kriegt die frauen einem blumenstrauß und
die männer in buch und da habe ich
gesagt das ist aber auch ein zeichen von
diskriminierung stille im saal weil
keiner wusste wie er damit umgehen
sollte nicht kannten ich bin natürlich
glücklich krieg nicht verstehen sie
warum nur oder
die mit dem buch weil ich finde männer
hatten auch einen blumenstrauß
warum nicht aber das buch nicht alle
bekommen das haben die männer mit thomas
gottschalk auch so am ende von wetten
dass gab es immer für dich mal frauen
betrifft wenn es das buch war ein
sportwagen buch insofern war es denn sie